Last year's class of 2015 was sent off into the world...
...as the most indebted class in history,...
...owing more than an average of a whopping $35,000.
And they're not alone.
Seventy-one percent of college kids today are taking out student loans...
...for an undergraduate degree, which now costs more than $100,000 on average.
They're joining the 40 million people in this country...
...that are burdened with student debt.
And with wages stagnant, that means it's a lot harder to settle down,...
...buy a house to start a family or save for retirement.
More and more people are pushing these things further and further back...
...because they're still paying off their tuition 21 years after graduating.
Maybe that's why 43% of folks with government student loans...
...aren't making their payments.
In 2015, the average state was spending 20% less per student than in 2007...
...before the financial crisis.
That means universities are raising tuition fees to make up the difference.
Altogether, students who went to college in the US...
...owe 845 billion dollars.
And it's a lucrative business for the federal government,...
...which owns most of that debt.
But does getting an education have to be this expensive?
Check out what this American student in Germany had to say.
You get much more value for your money here.